[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها كالمعتاد بالعناوين
صيني يجدد التوتر استدعاء القائمه باعمال
الصين في واشنطن تدعو بالتهدئه
الامراض الوراثيه تؤرق الاسر معدلاتها
مرتفعه في السعوديه وزواج الاقارب السبب
الاكبر
اول حافله كهربائيه لنقل الركاب في جده
شحنه واحده تكفي لقطع 300 كيلو متر
في الرابعه ايضا
استمرار اعمال التطوير في قلعه زعبل في
شمال السعوديه شاهد تاريخي يمتد لاربعه
قرون
ازمه تجدد التوتر بين الصين والولايات
المتحده هذه المره عبر منطاد تجسس صيني في
سماء الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
صاحبها الكثير من ردود الافعال من الطرفين
احدثها ما نقلته صحيفه
الامريكيه القائمه بالاعمال الصيني
جورنال كشفت ايضا ان لجنتين استخبارات في
الكونغرس يطالبان بالرد على منطاد التجسس
الصيني ومن جهتها نقلت صحيفه بلومبرج عن
رئيس الامريكي بايدن انه رفض نصيحه البنتا
باسقاط منطاد التجسس الصيني خوفا من سقوط
حطامه على المدن
اجواء مشحونه بين واشنطن وبيكين في الارض
والسماء تسبق زياره مرتقبه لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي الى بكين من تادون صيني يحوم في
سماء امريكا لاهداف تجسسيه وتعقب متواصل
لمسار حركه المنطاد من قبل البنتاجون لكن
اسقاطه لم يعد امرا واردا نظرا لما قد
يشكله من اضرار على مناطق سكنيه وفق ما
ذكر مسؤول دفاعي امريكي كبير تصريحات
مسؤول الدفاع الامريكيه اوضحت مسار ووجهه
المنطاد الصينيه فقبل عده ايام اخترق
المنطاد الصيني المجال الجوي الامريكي
ونحو قواعد جويه ومخازن صواريخ استراتيجيه
في ولايه مونتانا شمال غربيه امريكا يحلق
المنطاد عاليا على ارتفاع اعلى بكثير من
الحركه الجويه التجاريه وعاقب مشاورات
عسكريه امريكيه اقترب الطائرات مقاتله من
المنطاد فوق مونتانا دون ان تتخذ قرارا
باسقاته وفقا لوكاله الانباء الفرنسيه فان
واشنطن ابلغت بكين بخطوره الواقعه موضحه
انها ستفعل كل ما هو ضروري لحمايه شعبها
على اراضيها تحذير واجهته الصين بدعوه لحل
المساله بهدوء وحذر
لا ننوي انتهاك اراضي اي دوله او مجالها
الجوي يجب حل المساله بهدوء وحذر ولا
معلومات عن زياره مرتقبه لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي الى الصين اما مجلس النواب
الامريكي فطلب الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه
بعدم الصمت ما تقوم به الصين عمل مزعزع
للاستقرار ويتجاهل سياده الولايات المتحده
بدون خجل ادعو الرئيس بايدن الى عدم
التزام الصمت وابلاغ اعضاء الكونجرس
بالمستجدات
من جهته طلب الرئيس بايدن من وزير الدفاعه
بحث الخيارات المتاحه مع قيادات الجيش في
البنتاغون ووفقا لبيان وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه فان المنطاد لا يشكل تهديدا
عسكريا او جسديا لمن هم على الارض وعلى
الرغم من القيمه المحدوده للمنطاد
استخباراتيا وفق مسؤولين الا انه قد يزيد
من حده التوترات الصينيه الامريكيه
العسكريه والسياسيه في شرق اسيا علي
السمان العربيه
من امام الكابيتول ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه حسين التوت حسين مرحبا بك حسين
اريد
ان اسالك وين الامر يعني فيه الكثير من
الغرابه من طرد بحجم ثلاثه باصات تقريبا
كما تقول الروايه الامريكيه
يقطع مسافه اكثر من
2480 ميل من الاسكا في شمال الى مونتانا
لا يكتشفه سوى مواطن عادي يرصده بكاميرا
موبايل وبشكل كذلك يدعو الى الى الى
السخريه كيف كيف يمكن النظر الى هذه
الروايه يعني وهذا هذه الامر او المنطاد
المفاجئ في سماء الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
صباح الخير خالد بالفعل كل شيء غريب حول
هذا المنطاد وحتى اذا عرفنا ان الصين
لديها اقمار صناعيه اصلا تحلق فوق
الولايات المتحده في الفضاء الخارجي
ولديها القدره على التجسس وعلى التقاط
الصور عاليه الدقه وهذا ايضا يطرح تساؤلات
عده لماذا ترسل هذا المنطاد ليحلق في علوم
مرتفع هو فوق العلوم الذي تحلق فيه طائرات
المدنيه والتجاريه ولكن ايضا هذا سؤال
مطروح بقوه ما حاجتها لهذا المنطاد طبعا
كل ما تفضلت به هناك الان معلومه جديده
قراته قبل لي قبل قليل بان من اكتشف هذا
المنطاد هم ركاب على طائره تجاريه اصلا
كانوا يمرون فوق مونتانا هذا هذه
المعلومات كلها ادت الى توجيه انتقادات
عده اصلا من قبل مسؤولين هنا ونسيمه في
الكونغرس الامريكي هو خاصه من الجمهوريين
كبير الجمهوريين في لجنه القوات المسلحه
في مجلس الشيوخ روجرز انتقد وزاره الدفاع
وقال انها لم تتعامل مع قضيه المنطاد بشكل
طارئ وقال انه لا يجب السماح بحدوث هكذا
اختراق للاجواء الامريكيه ايضا اليوم
السيناتور تنقاطا ووسيره جمهوري بارز في
مجلس الشيوخ طالب باسقاط هذا المنطاد
واكتشاف ما هي المعلومات التي تم الحصول
عليها من قبل الصينيين الامور تتفاعل وكما
تفضلت في الخبر في رئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي ايضا طلب بتقديم معلومات الى
قاده الكونجرس هناك ايضا دعوات للرئيس
بايدن لا يتوقف عن السياسه التي يصفونها
بالسياسه اللينه وسياسه استرضاء الصين
واتخاذ قرارات حازمه خاصه قبيل الزياره
المرتقبه لوزير الخارجيه انطوني بلينكن
الى الصين الاسبوع المقبل اذا هناك
تفاعلات الان في الولايات المتحده بشان
هذا الاختراق اذا كان بالف هو من طابق
صيني حتى الان هناك ممكن ترجيحات بانه
منطاد صيني ولكن يضع علامات استفهام كثيره
نعم هل يمكن ان تمرر يعني هذه المساله
مساله اختراق يعني لمنطقه بهذا الحجم يقطع
كل هذه المسافه في وجود اجهزه واقمار
اصطناعيه هي الاولى على مستوى العالم خاصه
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ثم روايه
الرئيس الامريكي بانه رفض نصيحه البنت
البنتاجون باسقاط المنطاد خوفا من سقوط
حطامه على المدن الا يرصد اولا كل هذه
المسافه ثم ان لا يسقط خوفا على على
سقوطها على من سقوطه على ضحايا هل كل هذه
المنطقه 2400 مللي هي كلها مناطق ماهوله
بالسكان حتى يعني يصعب اسقاطها
عاده في المناطق الشماليه في الولايات
المتحده وخاصه هناك الكثير من الغابات
ولكن لربما هو في منطقه بالفعل فوق مدينه
معينه عندها سيصعب اسقطه قد يتناثر وقد
يسقط على مساحات شاسعه يتواجد فيها
مواطنون ولكن اذا ربما اذا طار لمسافه
ابعد واصبح فوق منطقه يمكن اعتبارها منطقه
نائيه اي عدد السكان فيها اقل ربما
يتعاملون معها بطريقه مختلفه ولكن ايضا
نتحدث تقنيا يمكن لربما يمكن احداث اختراق
معين ما يؤدي الى هبوط هذا المنطاد بشكل
تدريجي ولكن حتى الان يبدو ان الامريكيين
اما لا يعرفون طبيعه الماده المركبه او
المصنعه لهذا المنطاد ربما اذا تم
استهدافها برصاصه او استهدافها باي شيء
ربما تنفجر في الفضاء او في الغلاف عفوا
في الاجواء الامريكيه مياده الى تماثلها
الا اذا كان من نوع مطاط مثلا او من نوع
هناك
مستخدمه في صناعته او تكون به مواهب بشكل
تدريجي هذا هذه كل هذه الامور يجب هذه
كلها الامور يجب ان تدرس قبل عفوا ذهب
البعض
البعض ذهب الى انه تقوم
لذلك يجب ان يكونوا حذرين كما قال الرئيس
الامريكي هذه كيف ستؤثر على زياره الرئيس
اوزيل الخارجيه
يعني هل كان من ضمن العمليه عدم مثلا الان
بدانا نسمع الكثير من الانتقادات
سامحني على تاخر الصوت حسين نريد بس فقط
هل ستؤثر على مساله زياره وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي الى الى بكين وهي الزياره الاولى
لوزير خارجيه امريكي من ست سنوات تقريبا
حتى الان الزياره قائمه لم يعلن عن
الغائها او اي شيء من هذا القبيل ولكن من
المؤكد ان هذا الموضوع سيكون على اولويات
الملفات التي سيناقشها الوزير انطوني
بلينكن مع المسؤولين الصينيين خلال
زيارتها الاسبوع المقبل هنا ونسيمه في ظل
الدعوات الان الى طرح هذا الموضوع بقوه
ولا الى توقف عن سياسه الاسترضاء كما
يصفها الجمهوريون للرئيس بايدن تجاه الصين
هذا الموضوع بالفعل موضوع يؤثر على
الملفات التي ستناقش طبعا الا اذا حدثت
هناك الان تطورات اخرى من هنا الى اسبوع
لا نعرف كيف ستكون الامور ولكن حتى الان
الزياره قائمه ومن المتوقع بقوه ان يكون
موضوع المنطاد هو من ابرز الملفات التي
سيتم مناقشتها طبعا ليست الاختراقات
الصينيه وبالمناسبه حسب ما قرانا هذا ليست
اول مره الصين ترسل
تتهم بارسال
الى الاجواء الامريكيه هناك معلومات عن
انها ارسلت قبل ذلك عدد منها هذا لكن هذا
المنطاد اخذ ضجه بسبب اكتشافه الان بواسطه
مواطنين مدنيين وايضا كما ذكرت احدى الصحف
الامريكيه بان احد الركاب في على طائره
تجاريه صور المنطاد في اجواء مونتانا هذا
الموضوع موضوع
التجسس الصيني الامريكي هو موضوع قديم ليس
جديدا يعني والكثير من التقارير الامريكيه
كتبت وكذلك الغربيه عن تجسس صيني في
الولايات المتحده وفي دول اوروبيه كثيره
يعني ولكن تجسس كان بوسائل هادئه ربما
توغل في مناطق معينه عبر الشخصيات معينه
تكشف او لا تكشف في اجهزه معينه كذلك لكن
ان يتم الحديث اليوم عن تجسس بطريقه
مفضوحه يعني
مختلفه تماما هنا كيف سيؤثر على على على
على على هذه المساله تحديدا يعني في ضوء
المطالبات
موقف ربما اكثر صراما وتشددا الان مع هذا
الملف بين البلدين
خالد لا ننسى ايضا ان هناك اتهامات وجهت
لشركه تيك توك هناك دعوات لحضر هذا هذه
الابليكيشن هنا في الولايات المتحده
بالنسبه لموظفين الموظفين الفيدراليين
الصين حاولت اكثر من مره وفقا الامريكيين
التجسس عبر عده وسائل كانت تقنيه والان
هذا كما يقال انه منطاد صيني طبعا سيكون
هناك سياسات اكثر تشددا حتى في داخل
الكونغرس الامريكي متاكد بانه سيطرح قريبا
عدد من المشاريع
سيتبناها عدد من الاعضاء
الجمهوريه والديمقراطيين
لمواجهه هذه الموجه الصينيه من التجسس ومن
محاوله اختراق الولايات المتحده نذكر هناك
مشاريع الان تقدم بها السيناتور تم قاطا
اضافه الى السيناتور مارك روبيو وهو كبير
الجمهوريين في لجنه الاستخبارات الامريكيه
وهناك عدد اخر الاعضاء يؤيدونهما بهذه
الاجراءات من المؤكد انه بعد هذه الحاله
بعد هذا الاختراق بواسطه البالون بالفعل
اذا كان منتظم صينيا سيكون هناك عدد من
المشاريع سنرى تحركات داخل مجلس النواب
ومجلس الشيوخ الامريكي لتشريع عدد من
القوانين لمواجهه الهيمنه الصينيه او عفوا
التدخل الصيني او النفوذ الصيني المتزايد
والتي تحاول من خلاله الصين
التجسس على الولايات المتحده على ان كنا
نتحدث عن الوكالات الفيدراليه او على
اشخاص معينين والان هناك هذه الطريقه
الجديده ربما بمحاوله اختراق الاجواء
الامريكيه والتي لا يستسيغها الامريكيون
ويرفضونها ان كنا نتحدث عن وزاره الدفاع
او عن مجلس الشيوخ ومجلس النواب كما ذكرت
هناك الان دعوات للتعامل بصرامه مع هذا
الموضوع هناك انتقادات وجهت لوزاره الدفاع
لكي ف لم تكتشفه واكتشف من قبل مواطن
المدنيين ودعوات لاسقطه في اسرع وقت ممكن
ولمعرفه ماذا تحتويه او ماذا يحتوي هذا
المنطاد شكرا جزيلا لك حسين مراسل العربيه
من امام الكابت في واشنط
ن هذا وصف الكاتب الصحفي الصيني نادر
رانجل اتهامات الامريكيه المتعلقه بمنطاد
التجسس الصيني بانها غير منطقيه لان من
غير الممكن ان تستعين الصين بهذه الوسيله
البدائيه لممارسه التجسس على حد قوله تجسس
بوسيله المطاط هي وسيله بدائيه جدا
وكذلك
اذا كان هناك التجسس فلماذا لم تقم
باسقاطها الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا وبالتزامن
مع قمه اوكرانيه اوروبيه سمعت صافرات
الانذار في العاصمه كييف واعلنت شارل
ميشيل رئيس المجلس الاوروبي عبر حسابه على
تويتر عن تواجده في كييف لحضور قمه
الاتحاد الاوروبي مع كل من الرئيس
الاوكراني ورئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل
وممثل الشؤون الخارجيه للاتحاد الاوروبي
جزء جوزيف وكان ميشيل في تغريدته على عدم
التهاون فيما يخص الازمه في اوكرانيا
معبرا عن التضامن مع اوكرانيا في رحلتها
للانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
قمه روبيه اوكرانيه فيك في القمه هي
الرابعه والعشرون بين الطرفين وهي الاولى
من نوعها منذ حصول اوكرانيا على صفه
الدوله المرشحه لعضويه الاتحاد الاوروبي
حذيفه عادل من داخل قاعه انعقاد المؤتمر
الصحافه العالميه والعربيه والحدث في داخل
قاعه المؤتمرات حيث المؤتمر الصحفي للقمه
الاوروبيه الاوكرانيه في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه هي نحن هنا حيث سينعقد هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي للرئيس فلودي ورئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه اورسولا فون لاين
وكذلك رئيس المجلس الاوروبي تشارل ميشيل
هذه المفاوضات استمرت في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه لمده يومين التقى فيها كبار
المفوضين والمسؤولين في المفوضيه
الاوروبيه بالمسؤولين وبالحكومه
الاوكرانيه اجريت عمليه مفاوضات شارك فيها
الرئيس فلاديمير وحكومته وكذلك اجريت بعض
الاجتماعات بين بعض المسؤولين ومسؤولين
حكوميين اوكرانيين هنالك قضايا رئيسيه
واساسيه في اتجاه التكامل الاوروبي للدوله
الاوكرانيه التي تسعى طبعا للاندماج في
الاتحاد الاوروبي والدخول الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي قضيه القضاء واستقلاليه القضاء
والاصلاح في القضاء الاو في هذه احدى اهم
القضايا هنا حيث اقف وفي هذه المنصه سوف
يكون بعد قليل المؤتمر الصحفي للرئيس
الاوكراني ورئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
وكذلك رئيس المجلس الاوروبي شارل ميشيل
حيث سيتم الاعلان عن نتائج هذه المفاوضات
الاوروبيه الاوكرانيه لقناتها العربيه
والحدث حذف عادل
وقبل ذلك طلب الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير
زيلينسكي بمنح فرصه حقيقيه لبلاده
للانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي وقال انه
يعتقد ان اوكرانيا تستحق هذا العام الوصول
الى بدايه المفاوضات بشان عضويه الاتحاد
الاوروبي مؤكدا ان خطوه الاندماج مع
الاتحاد ستمنح الاوكرانيين الطاقه والحافز
للقتال على الرغم من اي عقبات وتهديدات
على حد وصفه
وافقت الحكومه الالمانيه على تسليم
اوكرانيا دبابات اليورود واحد في وقت اكد
فيه رئيس الوزراء النرويجي يونس جاستور في
مؤتمر صحفي عزمه سلطات بلاده على شراء على
شراء اربعين دبابه من طراز اثنين من شركه
المانيا كما اعلنت توصل الى اتفاق لشراء
ثماني عشره وحده اخرى من المعدات
في الرابعه بعد الفاصل صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه
الامريكيه اي وقعان اتفاقيه لانشاء مزارع
عموديه داخل السعوديه
هي اكثر مناطق العالم سخونه بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
صراع معقد خيارات صعبه
لواقع يوسع الفجوه بين الطرفين
الصراع الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي
على واحده انا مع هذا الكلام لكن لست مع
اختلاف في توازن القوه في المن يظهر الوجه
الانساني لهذا الصراع ويبحث في تاريخه
القديم والحديث في ظل غياب الحلول
الوثائقي الصراع الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي
السلام المستحيل الليله الواحده بعد منتصف
الليل على شاشه العربيه
هذه البلده الاستراتيجيه التي سيطرت عليها
القوات الروسيه منذ اليوم الاول التي تم
قصفها هنا في هذا المكان
توثيق هذه اللحظات هذا المبنى الذي قصف
ما زالت الاشتباكات مستمره هذه قنبله
يدويه لم تنفجر بعدها نحن الان في مدينه
بريديانكا الواقعه خارج حدود المناطق
الانفصاليه القديمه
نحن اول محطه نصل الى هذا المكان عندنا
هنا في دانياسكا اليوم
حقيقه الامر بالفعل هنالك مقبره جامعيه
ايضا على هذه الممرات
هذه الجوله الحصريه التي تمكنا من الحصول
عليها ودخول بلده بوتشا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد احصائيات مقلقه حول
مصابين الامراض الوراثيه للمواليد في
السعوديه كشف عنها البرنامج الوطني لفحص
الامراض الوراثيه عند المواليد في احدى
الحملات التوعويه الخاصه بالبرنامج واشارت
الاحصائيه الى ان السعوديه هي من اعلى
الدول في معدلات الاصابه بالامراض
الوراثيه السبب الاكبر زواج الاقرب
قرار خاطئ قد يجعل حياه الالاف من الاطفال
ناقصه ومليئه بالمعاناه نتيجه مرض وراثي
في السعوديه فقط تسجل اصابه واحده
بالامراض الوراثيه لكل الف مولود بمعدل
يقترب من خمسه اضعاف المعدلات العالميه
معروف ان الامراض الوراثيه المتنحيه نتيجه
زواج الاقارب تكون اكثر اذا كان اذا كان
هذا الشيء اللي هو منتشر فنسبه الامراض
الوراثيه عندنا متنحيه اكثر من دول الغرب
بالعكس حتلاقي دول الغرب عندهم الامراض
المتعلقه بالكروموسومات او الامراض
السائده اكثر من المتنحيه لانه ما عندهم
زواج اقارب فنحن نعتبر من الدول التي
تنتشر فيها بكثره اللي هو الامراض
الوراثيه المتنحيه زواج الاقارب يعد سبب
الاول لارتفاع معدلات الاصابه بالامراض
الوراثيه في السعوديه ما دفع وزاره الصحه
الى تنفيذ خطه كبرى لتخصيص استشاري لكل
اسره سعوديه ضمن التجمعات الصحيه في المدن
بهدف تعزيز الوقايه الصحيه والكشف مبكرا
عن الامراض ومعالجتها احنا برنامج طبيب
لكل اسره هو برنامج يهدف لمتابعه المريض
بشكل دوري تقريبا احنا عندنا كل اسبوع
لقاء مع فريق مكون من ممرض منسق حاله
ومدرب صحي يتناقشون في حالات المرضى او
يتم التواصل معهم الهاتفيا لمتابعتهم طبعا
لمتابعه تكون عن طريق وضع خطه علاجيه اما
كان علاجيا او وقائيا
ما قبل الزواج في السعوديه لا يكشف الا عن
مرضين وراثيين من بين الاف الامراض ولم
يحقق نتيجه في الحد من الامراض الوراثيه
على الرغم من التوصيات المستمره بزياده
انواع الامراض الوراثيه التي يشملها فحص
الزواج الالزامي من الرياض نواف عزيز
العربيه
هل هناك زياده في اعداد المصابين بهذه
الامراض الوراثيه
من الاقارب الذين يتزوجون بالرغم من من
ايجابيه الفحوصات التي تتم في هذا
البرنامج
اولا اشكركم على الدعوه واشكر العربيه على
جهودها في نشر التوعيه بالامراض الوراثيه
بالنسبه
لفحص الزواج هو يعتني بامراض الالتهابات
الكبد الفيروسي وايضا الامراض
المتوسط اللي هي منتشره عندنا بشكل كبير
برضو في المنطقه
الى حد ما
وربما يعني يمكن حالات الامراض المتعلقه
بالدم قلت ان اول نعم قلت بكثير لكن هناك
امراض وراثيه اخرى يعني
مثل ايش مثل
القصور الغده الدرقيه هذا مرض وراثي مثل
التليف الكيسي ليصيب
الرئه والجهاز الهضمي هذا برضو مرض ورا
مثل الضمور العضلات برضو من امراض
المنتشره عندنا مرض وراثي
نامل انه في المستقبل يكون في يعني تركيز
اكبر على
الامراض الاخرى غير امراض الدم التي بلا
شكل البرنامج نجح بشكل كبير في الحد من
انتشارها
ايش اخطر الامراض اللي ما زالت موجوده
الامراض الوراثيه دكتور لانه في حالات
كثير من اعاقات نشوفها باقارب تزوجوا وهم
في سن شاب يعني في سن صغيره ولديهم اثنين
او ثلاثه يعني من هؤلاء الاطفال المصابين
بس دعني اوضح نقطه مهمه الامراض الوراثيه
بشكل عام بشكل عام ما في لا يوجد هناك
علاج جذري
ممكن ياخذوا المريض ويتم الشفاء الكامل
وتعديل وتعديل الطفره الوراثيه انما هناك
علاج مساعد
مساند علاج تاهيلي علاج وظيفي اما
العلاجات التي
يعني تكون لها فائده اكبر هي المشموله
الان في البرنامج الفحص المواليد اللي هي
18 مرض استقلابي مع مرضين في الغده في
الغده الصماء اللي هم الغده الدرقيه
والغده البار كفري
في حالات ماساويه كتير الدكتور انا اريد
ان اسال عن هذه هذه تحديدا انت تعرف انه
الفحص الزواج ملزم ويمكن يعني يوفر لكثير
من الناس الامكانيه انه ينظر لمستقبل
الزواج ومستقبل اسرته واطفال لكن بالرغم
من ذلك التقيد بالنتيجه غير ملزمه للطرفين
بمعنى ممكن تكون النتيجه غير متوافقه
وممكن كذلك هذا التحليل او هذا الفحص وصحح
لي يعني انت المتخصص اكثر ممكن يتنبا بما
يمكن ان يحدث ومع ذلك يكون هناك يعني
اصرار من الطرفين على الزواج
الا يجب ان يتم الان اعاده النظر في هذا
الامر مراعاه لهذه يعني الحالات التي
نراها يعني مازلنا نراها بالرغم من كل هذه
البرامج
اتفق معك انه انه انه لا زالت هناك حالات
وفيها يصر الزوجان على اكمال اكمال عمليه
الزواج رغم رغم تحذيراتنا لهم ونصحنا لهم
انه ممكن يكون في اولاد
مصابين بمرض الانيميا مجليه او بحر
المتوسط دكتور اسالك علميا كم نسبه انه
نتائج هذا الفحص تكون صحيحه بمعنى انه
انتم ستتلقون ابناء يعني لديهم مشكله
وراثيه
هو اذا كان في علامات في التحليل المبدئي
اللي هو التحليل الدم
فهما الخطوه الثانيه انهم بيعملوا
يعملوا اللي هو
قياس لتركيز الهيموجلوبين والخاص
والبروتين الخاص بالانيمه المجاليه او
البحر المتوسط
نسبه
الدقه يعني كبيره تصل الى 90% نعم من ذلك
يصر الطرق الطرفان على الزواج بالرغم من
كل نعم احنا فقط مجرد ننصح ونرشد ونوضح
للعائله انه ممكن يكون في اولاد وممكن
يكون في اصابات
ومعاناه للاهل في التنويم المتكرر لما
نقول 90% تشوف انه يجب ان يعاد في قرار
مساله
التقيد بنتيجه من الطرفين من عدم من من
ناحيه طبيه دكتور
وحتى انسانيه كمان يعني
ما يعني سواء سواء الدراسات اللي احنا
درسنا فيها واول المراكز الطبيه لم يكن
هناك الزام من قبلنا كاطباء على الاهل
بانهم لا يجب ان يتزوجوا للزواج هناك
نصائح هناك ارشادات لكن كاطباء لا يمكننا
بشكل
بشكل صارم انه نخبر الاهل بعدم او او بعدم
اكمال الزواج يعني نحن مجرد ننصح ونرشد
طبعا هم يتحملوا مسؤوليه اذا كانوا حبوا
يكملوا في العمليه ام لا شكرا جزيلا لك
المشرف على برنامج الوطني فحص الامراض
استشاري الورات الطبيه الدكتور ضياء اعرف
شكرا
في السعوديه اعلن صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه عن توقيع اتفاقيه الامريكيه لتاسيس
شركه في الرياض تهدف الى انشاء مزارع
عموديه داخليه في المملكه شركه او شراكه
ستسهم في توفير محاصيل محليه عاريه الجوده
على مدار السنه من خلال استخدام تقنيه
الزراعه الذكيه الخاصه بشركه من المتوقع
ان يصل حجم الطاقه
الانتاجيه السنويه لاول مزرعه في المملكه
1100 من المحاصيل الزراعيه لتكون الاكبر
من نوعها في منطقه الشرق الاوسط والشمال
الافريقي
قد دشن ايضا في جده غربيه السعوديه ملتقى
الاحتفاء باللغه العربيه للشعوب الاسلاميه
في مقر منظمه التعاون الاسلامي تنظيم
الملتقى جاء ضمن حزمه من البرامج اللغويه
والمبادرات المتصله بتعزيز حضور اللغه
العربيه بمشاركه شخصيات اعتباريه ممثله في
منظمه التعاون الاسلامي ومجمع الملك سلمان
العالمي للغه العربيه وفي غيرها من
المنظمه
من جانبه ذكر الامين العام لمجمع الملك
سلمان العالمي للغه العربيه الدكتور عبد
الله الوشمي ان السعوديه تستعد لاقامه
فعاليه كبرى تتعلق باللغه العربيه في مقر
منظمه التجاره العالميه وذلك ضمن جهود
كبرى ايضا لتقويه اللغه العربيه عالميا
ينعقد هذا الملتقى بالتعاوني الوثيق مع
منظمه التعاون الاسلامي وهي ثاني اكبر
المنظمات الدوليه وبرعايه كريمه من صاحب
السمو الامير بدر بن عبد الله بن فرحان ال
سعود وزير الثقافه السعودي رئيس مجلس
امناء المجمع وذلك ضمن جهود مجمع الملك
سلمان العالمي للغه العربيه في تعزيز حضور
اللغه العربيه في المنظمات الدوله الدوليه
حيث قام المجمع وبرمجه الكبير في ديسمبر
الماضي في مقر منظمه الامم المتحده
ويستعدوا قريبا لاقامه فعاليه كبرى في مقر
منظمه التجاره العالميه وذلك ضمن جهودي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في تعزيزي
وقياده شؤون اللغه العربيه في العالم
رابعا مستمره فيها بعد قليل استمرار اعمال
التطوير في قلعه زعبل في شمال السعوديه
شاهدون تاريخي يمتد لاربعه قرون
صينيه يجدد التوتر استدعاء القائم باعمال
الصين في واشنطن تدعو للتهدئه
الامراض الوراثيه تؤرق الاسر معدلاتها في
السعوديه مرتفعه وزواج الاقارب السبب
الاكبر
اول حافله كهربائيه لنقل الركاب في جده
شحنه واحده تكفي لقطع 300 كيلومتر
واستمرار اعمال التطوير في قلعه زعبل في
شمال السعوديه شاهد تاريخيا
اهلا بكم من جديد دشنه الهيئه العمل للنقل
في السعوديه اول حافله نقل عام
كهربائيه في المملكه في مدينه جده ستقدم
خدماتها للسكان ضمن مسارات النقل العام
الايه واشارت الى ان هذه الخطوه تستهدف
تحقيق مستهدفات الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه
للنقل والخدمات اللوجستيه وذلك بخفض
الانبعاثات الكربونيه بنسبه
25% بحلول العام
2030 الهيئه ايضا كشفت بان الحافله التي
جرى تشغيلها او تدشينها تستطيع السير ل
300 كيلو متر في الشحنه الواحده وتعد من
الحافلاتات الكفاءه العاليه وتستهلك
الكهرباء باقل من 10% مقارنه
بالحافلات الكهربائيه الاخرى
رئيس الهيئه العامه للنقل رماح الرماح ان
خطوه التدشين اول حافله كهربائيه في جده
تاتي ضمن خطه لتجربتها ومن تم اعتمادها في
كافه مناطق السعوديه وذلك لتحقيق مستهدفات
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للنقل والخدمات
اللوجستيه
اول تجربه لحافله كهربائيه لتجربتها في
جده في اجواء جده في على مدار الموسم
لاختبارها ثم
توزيعها ونشرها في مدن المملكه المختلفه
حرصا من تقليل الانبعاثات من سيارات النقل
العام او مركبات النقل العام لدينا مستهدف
ان ينخفض تخفيض الانبعاثات الى 25% من
الانبعاثات هذا وكشف رئيس شركه السعوديه
للنقل الجماعي خالد الحقيل ان الاجواء
سواء الحاره او البارده جدا تعد من ابرز
التحديات التي تواجه استخدام الحافلات
الكهربائيه مشيرا الى ان نتائج الاختبارات
في مرحلتها الحاليه تعد جيده
اليوم الاهميه تكمن في قضيه المملكه اليوم
تنتقل مع الركب العالمي في استخدام
الحافلات الكهربائيه الصديقه للبيئه
لتقليل الانبعاثات جزء منه
للحصول على حافلات اليوم صديقه للبيئه
وتتناسب مع اليوم التطور اللي يصير في
صناعه النقل اليوم الحافلات الكهربائيه لا
شكلنا من التحديات في قضيه اليوم الاجواء
الحاره او البارده جدا طبعا حنا اليوم
فدينا في اول خط في مدينه جده مدشنه لنضع
الاختبارات اللي لها الحمد نتائجها مبشره
من جده ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه سعود
الخلف سعود مرحبا بك
سعود انت تتواجد الان بجانب احدى هذه
الحافلات الكهربائيه يعني سؤالك عن هذه
الحافله ما هي مواصفاتها هل جدا مؤهله
لتقديم الدعم اللوجستي يعني لهذا من توفر
بطاريات شواحن ايضا في الطرق التي تسلكها
هل الجده باجوائها ايضا يمكن ان تكون مكان
مناسب لهذه الحافلات معروفه اجواء جده
يعني وخاصه في الصيف
في الرياض ما شاء الله عايشين اجواء ولا
احلى مع الشتاء الله يعين بس عموما مثل ما
ذكرت انت في بدايه الخبر يوم امس كان
تدشين لهذه الحافلات اليوم اول رحله
ستنطلق لهذه الحافله واحنا بناخذ جوله
وبناخذ معلومات كثيره يا خالد طبعا هي
حافله كهربائيه وهذا المكان هو المكان
الذي يتم شحن فيه الحافله بمده معينه طبعا
في معلومات كثيره منها اللي انت سالت عنها
خالد وراح نتعرف عليها ولكن بعد ان ندخل
الى الحافله ونتعرف عليها منه الاستاذ
محمد بن سعيد القحطاني وهو مدير مشروع
النقل في جده هاي اعطينا تفاصيل كثيره
يعطيك العافيه استاذ محمد
ومباركة هذه الخطوه باذن الله البدايه هل
جدا مؤهله لاستقبال هذه الحافلات
الكهربائيه من خلال المسارات وايضا
مشروع النقل هل هو مهيا للبطاريات
اعداد كافيه معلومات كثيره الناس تتساءل
عنها ومنها خالد زميلنا من الاستوديو اهلا
وسهلا حياك الله اخوي سعود شكرا على تاحه
الفرصه هذه لشرح مبسط بالنسبه
الكهربائيه طبعا بدايه كانت امس بحضور
معالي مدير رئيس هيئه النقل العام ومعالي
امين مدينه جده والحمد لله اليوم بدايه
تشغيل الحافله الكهربائيه على احدى مسارات
مشروع النقل العام بجده طيب يعني خلينا
نتكلم عن المسارات كم عندنا مسار وهل خصص
مسار معين ومحدد لهذه الحافله طبعا عندنا
مشاريع بالنسبه للمسارات عندنا ثمانيه
مسارات لمشروع النقل العام في جده طبعا تم
اضافه عليها بالنسبه للمسارات اللي هي
مسار مطار الحرمين ومسار قطار قطار الدولي
عبد العزيز الدولي وقطار الحرمين اضافه
طبعا نحن خصصنا الحافله الكهربائيه لاحدى
مسارات مشروع النقل العام اللي هي مسار
سبعه اللي هو الخالديه البلد حلو طب احنا
كم عندنا حافله حافله ثنتين ثلاثه بالنسبه
الان كتجربه هي حامله واحده الان تجربه
لحافله الكهربائيه ليش تجربه يعني ما في
ثقه في المساله ولا ايش والله اول شيء
الحافلات تحتاج الى تقييم لازم تقييم اي
مشروع تبطي تبدا تنفذه خاصه حول
الكهربائيه والاجواء اللي موجوده في
السعوديه مختلفه عن الاجواء الصين مختلفه
اوروبا فبالتالي تحتاج الى ثلاثه الى سته
شهور وبالتالي تقيم تجربتك بالنسبه
للحافله الكهربائيه جميل طيب احنا عندنا
حافله واحده كم المده التي تحتاجها لشحن
البطاريه بشكل كامل وكم المده التي
تستغرقها ايضا الحافله في نفاذ البطاريه
طبعا هي تستغرق شحن البطاريه من 20% الى
90% و100% تقريبا ساعه ونص الى ساعتين
طبعا تستغرق الى تقطع مسافه 300 الى 350
كيلو متر بالنسبه لكامل البطاريه
حافله واحده
والتجربه سته اشهر
مباركه لكم هذه الخطوه وان شاء الله بعد
سته اشهر سنلتقيكم لمعرفه تقييمكم لهذه
التجربه شكرا جزيلا لك عن النقطه هذه مو
تدشين
هو
ستستمر لمده من ثلاثه الى سته اشهر خلال
فتره هذه سيتم اقرار اما صحيح ان تستمر
وتتوقف بناء على التحديات وبناء على
الاجواء وغيرها من الامور
حسب حسب المعلومات يا خالد انه هذه
التجربه يعني سيشاهد ويقيموا ما هي
النواقص وما هي الايجابيات ان كان هنالك
نواقص سيتم اضافتها طبعا موجود معنا في
الحافله مدراء من الشركه
المنتجه
للناس الان
الحين قاعد اقول نخلص اللايف ونطلع معاهم
بس الاجواء ان شاء الله حلوه رحله سعيده
يا حبيبي وشكرا جزيلا لك سعود الخلف من
جده
اكبر مسابقه للصيد المستدام في السعوديه
انطلقت قبل ايام في شمال السعوديه في
محميه الشمال للصيد المستدامه هذه
المسابقه تهدف الى اكثار الطرائد بالاسر
ثم اطلاقها في بيئه طبيعيه جزاء يرافق احد
الصقارين في رحلتهم للبحث عن طائر الحبارة
نتابع
محميه الشمال للصيد المستدام اول محميه من
نوعها في السعوديه تم تدشينها حديثا على
مساحه 2000 كيلو متر مربع وهي من ابرز
المبادرات التي عملت عليها مؤخرا هيئه
تطوير محميه الامام تركي بن عبد الله
الملكيه الشمال للصيد المستدام هي محميه
مخصصه لصيد الحباري ما نعرف انه صدور مرور
تاريخي وثقافي بالنسبه لنا لسكان الجزيره
العربيه وهذا هو استمرار لهذا الموروث
التاريخ الثقافي والانساني على ارض
الجزيره العربيه ونطبح ان شاء الله ان
تكون هذه المحميه والمسابقه اللي تليها
جزء بسيط من هذا التفعيل اكبر مسابقه من
نوعها في السعوديه للصيد المستدام انطلقت
في محميه الشمال وبالطريقه التراثيه وهي
الصيد بالصقور والطرائد هي الحباري التي
تم اطلاقها في بيئتها لتكون قابله للصيد
بشكل يومي على مدى عشره ايام في عمليه
تنافسيه بين 600 صقار تم اختيارهم من اصل
ثمانيه الاف متقدم 600 متسابق تم اختيار
بطريق القرعه الالكترونيه 600 متسابقه
بتوزعون على عشره ايام كل اربع متسابقين
في فريق وبالتالي بيدخلون في عمليه منافسه
عمليه منافسه ليست محصوره على الاسرع في
الصيد او الاقوى في الطير او غيره وانما
هدفها محصور هو على الاهداف اللي ظهرت
منها محميه الشمال للصيد المستدام محافظه
على البيئه المحافظه على الشروط البيئيه
محافظه ايضا كذلك على نظافه المحميه وايضا
الاسهام في نشر هذه الاهداف على نطاق
المحميه تسعى محميه الشمال للصيد المستدام
الى حمايه الحياه الفطريه وتنميه السياحه
البيئيه من خلال تطوير برنامج رياضي للصيد
المستدام معتمد على اكثار الطرائد بالاسر
وا في بيئه طبيعيه من محميه الشمال للصيد
المستدام جزاعا ماصي العربيه
[موسيقى]
منطقه الجوف في شمال السعوديه تضم حصونا
وقلاعاريه تعود الى مراحل زمنيه مختلفه
منها قلعه زعبل التي يعود بناءها الى
الفتره النبطيه الممتده من القرن الاول
قبل الميلاد في شمال مدينه سكاكا القلعه
التاريخيه يجري في محيطها حراك من التطوير
من خلال اعمال الترميم والانشاءات التي
تتكامل مع طبع العمراني والاثري للقلعه
وذلك لتعزيز وصول السياح والزوار كونها
تعد من المعالم التاريخيه والسياحيه
المهمه في المنطقه
من قناه زعبل او زعبل في منطقه الجو في
شمال السعوديه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
عبد الواحد عبد الحميد حياك الله عبد
الواحد عبد الواحد اولا الاسمين صح ولا
واحد منهم الصح ربما والامر الثاني خلينا
نتعرف اكثر على هذه القلعه معك
اهلا بك خالد نعم طبعا باللهجه نقول زعبل
هي الاكثر يعني انتشارا بين سكان المحليين
نحن هنا في هذه القلعه اسفل القلعه تحديدا
حيث هناك العديد من البيوت التاريخيه
والاثريه نحاول ان نريكم القلعه في الاعلى
هي قلعه شاهقه جدا اسفلها يوجد العديد من
البيوت والمنازل التاريخيه التي يتم فيها
طبعا تم فيها ترميم سابقا في هذه البيوت
بالنسبه للقلعه هناك طبعا كما تعلم اكثر
من 3000 سنه تقريبا عمر هذه القلعه
فيما يتعلق بتفاصيل هذه القلعه نود ان
نتعرف اكثر من خلال لقائنا بالاستاذ نايف
اللحيد وهو مهتم بتاريخ قلعه بل اهلا
وسهلا بك استاذ نايف نريد ان نعرف اولا
تفاصيل هذه القلعه مما تتكون طبعا القلعه
هي مبنيه على يعني على تقريبا على طول 50
متر وهي تتكون من الصخر الرملي وبها شيء
من الطين
فيها في الاعلى على اربع ابراج تتولى
المراقبه وتكمن اهميه القلعه قلعه زعبل في
ذلك الوقت وفي تلك الحقبه تحديدا بانها
طال عمرك مسؤوله عن حمايه الحي وحمايه
مدينه سكاكا والاشراف على الطرق التجاريه
في ذلك الوقت وايضا الحمايه فكان صمودها
يعني صمود الحي وصمود المدينه وسقوطها في
ذلك الوقت يعني سقوط مدينه سكاكا فالقلعه
تكمن اهميتها بكونها قلعه حربيه حصينه
مسؤوله عن حمايه المدينه والحج طيب
بالنسبه لطبعا
المواد اللي تم صناعه من هذه القلعه نعرف
ان القلعه تم ترميمها تقريبا في اخر 200
سنه او قبل 300 سنه تقريبا الرممه القلعه
على وقت القرش حقيقه وكان الهدف من
الترميم هو اعاده دفاعاتها وتحصينها ايضا
الابراج تم كان طولها قصير ورفعت الى خمس
امتار تقريبا
لاعاده ترميمها من جديد وتحصينها بالنسبه
لهذا المكان اللي نحن متواجدين فيه الحين
قصر المسقوف وش قصته هذا طال عمرك المسقوف
كان يجتمعون فيه في وقت الازمات وتحديدا
المشاكل تمر في تلك الحقبه في المنطقه كان
يتناول فيه المواضيع السياسيه في ذلك
الوقت وطرق علاجها وحلها والتعاون فيما
بينهم طيب اخيرا استاذ نايف يعني نعرف ان
هذا المكان يعد يعني احد رموز منطقه الجوف
وطبعا
حتى الزوار والسياح ياتون باستمرار الى
هذه المناطق لزياره المساكن التاريخيه
والمنازل اسفل القلعه طبعا هي يعني تعتبر
صراحه متنفس للجميع كونها يعني مكان
تاريخي طلع يعني يعبر عن اصاله المنطقه
وعرقتها وتاريخها بقلعتها الشامخه وبيوتها
التي تمثل وتحاكي البيوت الموجوده في
الجزيره العربيه
والناس يستمتعون حقيقه بالطلوع الى اعلى
القلعه والاطلاع على مدينه سكاكا الحي
يعني يتفرجون عليه طيب تاريخيا هذه
المناطق الاسفل القلعه كانت يعني حتى فيها
ربما البساتين وكانت مناطق الزراعيه نعرف
المنطق الجوف تعد من كبريات المناطق اللي
يعني منتشره فيها الزراعه
لخصوبه الارض الزراعيه في المنطقه طبعا
الاقتصاد في تلك الفتره وفي تلك حقبه
تحديدا يعتمد على الزراعه وتحديد زراعه
النخيل والنخله كما قال الرسول هيعمتنا
يعني وكان هي القوت التي يعتمد عليها
الاهالي القوه الغذائي ليعتمد عليها
الاهالي اللي هو التمر وكذلك يستفيدون من
حسبها بسقف البيوت المنازل وايضا حتى
الحيوانات حيوانات وبسيطه كانت تتغذى على
العشب ويسميه العشب حنا جريده النخل
فالنخله هي اقتصاد المنطقه في ذلك الوقت
شكرا جزيلا الاستاذ نايف الحيد على كل هذه
التفاصيل اللي زودنا فيها من اسفل قلعه
زعبل كما تشاهدون البيوت التاريخيه
العديده والمتنوعه اسفل هذه القلعه يزورها
الناس والزوار والسكان وحتى السياح
باستمرار
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من قناه في منطقه الجوف
في شمال السعوديه مراسل العربيه عبد
الواحد الحميد
في السعوديه اليوم الجمعه مهرجان
الملك عبد العزيز للابل بنسخته السابعه
بحضور امير منطقه الرياض الامير فيصل بن
بندر بن عبد العزيز وسلم امير الرياض
الفائزين في المهرجان جوائزهم التي تصل
قيمتها الى 300 مليون ريال سعودي المهرجان
ايضا الذي انطلق في الصياهد في شمال
الرياض بدايه من مطلع ديسمبر الماضي شهد
منافسات شديده بين مالكيليبل المشاركين من
المملكه ومن دول الخليج العربي والعالم
ايضا وسط حضور جماهيري كبير لمحبي الابل
اعلنا برنامج الغذاء العالمي استئناف صرف
المساعدات الغذائيه للنازحين في مارب في
اليمن بعد الوصول الى اتفاق مع الجهات
المعنيه وكانت الوحده التنفيذيه للنازحين
نشرت صورا لاتلاف كميات من المواد
الغذائيه من قبل البرنامج منعت عن
النازحين خلال الاشهر الماضيه
اربعه اشهر من الجدل حول توزيع مساعدات
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي على النازحين في
مارب بصمات العين لكافه افراد الاسره
المستفيده من الغذاء واشتراطات اخرى تمسك
بها البرنامج ورفضتها بقوه سلطات مارب
للحفاظ على امن وخصوصيه النازحين بسببها
توقفت عمليه صرف الغذاء وبدا شبح المجاعه
يلوح في مخيمات النزوح طبعا هو كان يقول
ان لديه اجراءات جديده ادخل هذا ضمن خطه
البرنامج هذه الاجراءات
لم توافق عليها الجهه الامنيه والسلطه
المحليه داخل المحافظه نحن نعتبر من حق
السلطان المحليه الحفاظ على او من حق
الدوله الحفاظ على مواطنيها
فيها في هذه المرحله نحن يهمنا النازحين
وضع النازحين ويهمنا الا تحصل كارثه
انسانيه ومجاعه داخل المحافظه
فات مراكز التوزيع لمباشره صرف المساعدات
المخزنه لاكثر من اربعه اشهر في دورته
السابعه من العام 2022
واعلن عبر منصاته التوصل لاتفاق مع السلطه
المحليه على استئناف الصرف دون التطرق لحل
المشكله من عدمه وفي عمليه الصرف هذه
استمر البرنامج بخفض كميات واصناف الغذاء
المقدمه للنازحين
وعليها كان على زوجه جريح ولزوجه استشهد
واللي ما بش معاها مقدرين انه يتمت حالتها
الان رجعوها كيس دقيق
وواحد بول يعني كيلو فول مدري كما هذا
والزيت هذا ما يستخدمه الناس
الجوع مع البرد يزيد من معاناته ثلاثه
ملايين من النازحين والمجتمع المضيف في
مارب فيما نشرت وحده النازحين صورا لمواد
غذائيه اتلفها برنامج الغذاء العالمي
اواخر يناير الماضي في مديريه رغوان دون
الرجوع للسلطات المعنيه في المحافظه بعد
اربعه اشهر من توقيفها كما تؤكد الوحده
التنفيذيه لاداره مخيمات النازحين يعود
برنامج الغذاء العالمي لصرف السله
الغذائيه للمواطنين ولكن بكميات اقل محمود
الحميدي لقناه العربيه مارب نختم
بالعناوين
يجدد التوتر استدعاء القائم باعمال الصين
في واشنطن تدعو للتهدئه والترامب يقول
اسقطه فورا
الامراض الوراثيه تعرق لوس المعدلاتها في
السعوديه مرتفعه وزواج الاقارب هو السبب
الاكبر
اول حافله كهربائيه لنقل الركاب في جده
شحنه واحده تكفي لقطع 300 كيلومتر
واستمرار اعمال التطوير في قلعه زعبل في
شمال السعوديه شاهد تاريخيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]